Chancellor of the Duchy of Lancaster
Michael Gove is with us now mr. go thank
you for joining us on the program so
many questions as a result of what the
Prime Minister had to say so little time
to ask them so here we go
who can go out we want to make sure that
people stay at home wherever they can
people can go out once day for exercise
a walk around or a cycle ride it's also
the case that people can go to the shops
in order to make sure they get essential
goods but generally wherever people can
stay at home they should the only people
who should not be staying at home are
those who absolutely need to be at their
place of work and who cannot work from
home and that means builders can go to
work in specific circumstances yes and
that means that people who work in car
rental offices can go to work it should
be the case that when it comes to cars
that garages should remain open in order
to ensure that people get the petrol
that they need in order to make sure
that they get the repairs that they need
but it shouldn't be the case that car
showrooms are open now not car showrooms
car rentals if it's appropriate in order
to make sure that people get the the
rental vehicle that they need but social
distancing should apply and I'm sure
that firms will recognize the importance
of making sure that if people do need
rental vehicles or people do need to get
access to additional cars that they do
so in a way which keeps both parties
safe okay we were looking at some
scenarios in the office this morning
questions as a result of our friends
talking to us let me put some of them to
you and hopefully you can clear this up
for us I'm a freelance journalist I'm
driving on the motorway my work is not
essential at this time will I be pulled
over by the police and will I have to
explain my movements it's unlike the
ring one's going to be pulled over by
the police but people should be at home
working at home wherever they can I am
taking a neighbor's dog for a walk
because they're too scared to go out and
do it themselves is that okay
it should be the case that that that
neighbor should do the dog walking
themselves we should minimize contact
between a
solds if you've got dogs at home and you
want to walk that dog of course you
should walk that dog but only one walk
or one other exercise a day I'm taking a
total for a walk in the park and there
are already other parents gathering in
large numbers do I contact the
authorities
you should wherever possible try to
encourage people not to gather in that
way and if you are genuinely worried
then of course contact the authorities
but it should be the case that if you
are for example going for a walk in the
park with a member of your immediate
family and you see other people
gathering in that way then if you can
you should try to seek to get them to
recognize the clear guidance that the
government is given you misspoke earlier
about what should happen to children who
have separated can you just clarify the
situation yes absolutely I was asked on
another program on piers morgan's good
morning Britain program about this and I
was not clear and thank you for giving
me the opportunity to be clear it is the
case that if you're divorced or
separated that and you and you have
children who are under the age of 18
those children can move from one parents
home to another parents home as
appropriate now we want to try to reduce
the amount of movement between homes but
that is a clear exception here and I I
want to make it clear that I was not
when I was being interviewed on Piers
Morgan's programme as clear as I should
have been in specifying that there is
this exception and also to be clear it's
Susanna Reed's program as well talk to
me about why these prime minister
decided to take the action that he did
last night why is it taking so long
though the promise of fall is scientific
advice and we act at the right time
given the the data that we have the
facts that we have about the nature of
the spread of the disease we know what
you thought about experts in the past
why are you taking notice this time I
was quoted in the past about a small
group of economists I certainly believe
that when it comes to medicine that
scientists are people whose advice we
should take very seriously he had been
urged to go further for a while though
the Prime Minister had hadn't
did he finally realize reluctantly that
people in the United Kingdom would not
listen unless they were forced to well
naturally all of us would never want to
be in a position where we impose the
sorts of restrictions that are now being
imposed all of us are naturally people
who cherish the fact that the UK is a
land of liberty but we do need to take
steps in order to make sure that people
comply with the rules health and foreign
secretary one of your old colleagues
neither of those jobs anymore although
he is the chairman of the Health
Committee saying this is much too late
by the government talking about Jeremy
Hunt of course he said the writing was
on the roll on the wall and I wonder how
you think that history will look back at
this government's response whether even
when your own members of your own
colleagues think it was too little too
late I think the most important thing
now is not to look back but to do
everything that we can in order to
ensure that the the instructions that
have been put in place are followed
people will form their own judgment at
some point in the future what I'm
concerned about now is making sure that
we do everything possible to protect the
NHS and that means that wherever
possible people should stay at home do
you acknowledge that it could have been
too late we are too late in making these
decisions we knew what was happening
it's okay to say yeah you know it's okay
to accept our mistakes we knew what was
happening with China we knew what was
happening with Italy we thought that we
could convince the British public to
behave in a proper manner and they
didn't and we saw what happened at the
weekend the Sun came out they were
climbing Snowden I think that we've
followed advice at every stage on what
is the appropriate measure to take and I
think that's the right thing to do in a
democracy it's perfectly understandable
that people have a range of views and to
disagree judgments can be formed now
judgments will be formed in due course I
think the most important thing now
though is to do everything that we can
as individuals in our communities and in
government to do to follow the steps
which will limit the spread of this
disease how long do you think we'll be
in lockdown the prime minister said
three weeks during his address it wasn't
off-the-cuff you know it was scripted he
was reading it from an autocue three
weeks does that mean in three weeks time
we're all going to be okay we can go
back to work it means that we will
review in three weeks time exactly how
these measures are working let me be
clear this is a public health emergency
a national emergency we must do
everything that we can to stop this
virus spreading as the Prime Minister
said in his statement if the virus
spreads in an unconstrained way that
will overwhelm the health services of
any nation so that's why we're taking
the steps that we're taking that's why
it's vital that people follow them we
will keep it under review and in three
weeks time we'll be able to say whether
or not the the path that we followed
needs any further intensification or
whether there are volunteer of the
existing restrictions that may be
capable of being lifted but for the
moment the most important thing is that
people in the days ahead follow this
advice what is that three weeks look
like so over the next three weeks we're
going to see an increase daily on the
number of deaths is it going to we've
all seen the charts of how the graph
goes up even higher and quicker than
we've seen in Italy is that what you are
preparing for as government well one of
the things that we wanted to do and I
think other European countries are
taking a similar approach as well is to
ensure that we take the steps now in
order to reduce the spread of the virus
if you reduce the spread of the virus if
fewer people are infected then the
pressure on the NHS is reduced as well
and that means that the NHS can not only
treat those who are infected it can also
treat people with other conditions which
are life-threatening as well that is the
most critical thing and as a result of
the steps that that are being taken we
can alter the future they the spread of
infection is not something which is you
know entirely autonomous entirely
separate from our actions all of us as
individuals can play our part in
reducing the spread of infection and
that is an absolutely vital thing to do
in order to protect the NHS I wonder if
I could
press you though to answer the question
mr. go are we expecting hundreds if not
thousands of deaths over the next three
weeks it depends on what we do only
we're locking with people most people
are at home if people do what you're
asking are we still expecting hundreds
if not thousands of deaths before this
curve starts to pop and bottom out well
there are two things okay the first
thing is we want to make sure that we
limit infection if we limit infection
then we can limit the pressure on the
NHS and we can save more lives and then
the second thing of course is that we
need to make the NHS stronger and more
resilient and that means that the the
ventilators that we are bringing on
stream the personal protection equipment
that we are ordering the additional NHS
staff who've rallied to the cry to come
back and to to help all of those
resources and individuals can be
deployed on the frontline and we can
save more lives I don't want to get into
a game of predicting what will happen I
simply want to act now with others in
order to reduce the number of people who
are at risk give me a number please Mr
Gove I'm giving the opportunity to shock
people into staying at home and that in
order to do that it's to say if you
don't then thousands more people will
die well I think the thing is that
anyone who wants to know well how
important it is to stay at home if you
look at what's been happening in Italy
if you listen to those on the front line
of the NHS it is clear I don't think
that people need any further recognition
of the scale of what might happen unless
everyone takes appropriate action to
reduce infection then seeing the
terrible scenes that have occurred in
other country I wonder if that's true
mr. go cuz we've got some pictures to
show you people the tubes are absolutely
packed this morning people are not
listening they're not abiding by the
2-meter rule we had our helicopter up
over Battersea but Battersea lower ship
of that sort of area that is the hotspot
for the country at the moment for deaths
of coronavirus people are not listening
what they need is to be shocked into
realizing that if they continue to do
this I don't know you tell me hundreds
thousands more people will die tell me
it is the case that we unless people
take appropriate steps now then the NHS
will be under more strain and if the NGS
is under more strain than those that we
love those that we care for most our
risk of losing their lives and we can we
can talk about abstract numbers but I
think the most important thing for all
of us is to recognize that the human
relationships that we value depend on
protecting those that we care about and
all of us will have someone in our lives
who we know may be vulnerable because of
age or other factors we love them we
want them to stay safe the best way of
keeping them safe is to stay at home to
limit your time outside to that one
piece of exercise every day or that
minimum shopping that's the most
important thing but Mr Gove I'm a mother
you're a dad
why you tiptoeing through the raindrops
here why don't you just tell people who
are watching you you know our audience
figures are through the roof at the
moment people are desperate for
information why don't you just tell them
unless they stay at home hundreds and
thousands of people will die why don't
you just tell them that that is
something that will shock our viewers
into realizing that they can't go out
there can't go to the pub they can't
stand around in gatherings like we've
seen this morning it's continuing on
unless you stay at home then the people
you love most may die yes thank you what
about people who want to get out of the
city with their loved ones and go to
places like the Lake District or to the
north of Scotland or to their second
homes are they not then taking pressure
off the NHS in those areas where the
hotspots are no why not they should stay
at home they should not be at risk of
spreading the virus across the country
and nor should they be at risk of
putting a strain on the NHS in other
parts of the country the advice is clear
stay
at home and all non-essential travel
should end are you grounding flights it
is the case that we're doing everything
possible to reduce the number of flights
yes are we going to see airports like
Heathrow etc close down for night it is
the case that we keep under review the
operation of our airports but we also
need to make sure that wherever possible
is the foreign secretary made clear last
night that people who are currently
abroad who are UK citizens can come home
okay um are you confident that all Brits
that want to come home will be able to
get home in the in the time permitted
whether that's the end of the week or
whatever we're doing everything we can
to make that happen okay but you can't
guarantee that they'll be able to all
get home we will do everything we can
there may be some individual UK citizens
in particular parts of the world who may
decide to stay there rather than come
home but the Foreign Secretary and the
transport secretary are working
incredibly hard to make sure that
everyone who can come home is in a
position to be able to do so yeah